[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
the content of this program is to
provide nutritional education only this
program is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician the FDA
requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases as an
empowered individual you have options
available we are honored to have one of
the founding fathers of epigenetics here
to guide us with the best options to
obtain or maintain Optimal Health Dr
Joel Wallach welcome to daily with Doc
and Becca
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hello hello everybody
hello hello and welcome to daily with
Doc so glad to see all of you here with
us
waiting for everybody's uh
yeah audio that's the word I'm looking
for waiting for their audio to connect
um and then I'm gonna go ahead and get
started because I know when that audio
isn't connected you can't hear me either
whether you're speaking or not so I'm so
excited to have you all here with us and
for those of you who are watching the
live stream whether you're on Rumble
watching through critical Health news or
YouTube critical Health news or Facebook
just critical Health come on over join
us here on the live presentation of
daily with Doc zoom.com that's the URL
you can go to that will get you to our
Live program that we are recording at
this very minute for those of you who
are watching the live
um but it is also where you can join us
at future dates Monday through Friday
from noon to 1 Pacific Time one to two
mountain time two to three Central Time
and three to four Pacific time and of
course if you are in the UK that will be
eight to nine
unless they did a time change that I
can't remember or
um down in South Africa 11 to 12 p.m so
we are so excited to have you all here
with us whether you're watching us live
or watching the replay welcome to daily
with Doc now this program is being
sponsored by dailywithdoc.com where we
have all of our broadcasts from about
two and a half years we've we've had a
couple different programs and broadcasts
that we have been bringing to the masses
and
I am so honored to be the hostess of
those programs where we are providing
empowering information that enables you
as an individual to write your health
Journey so and we're talking right as in
right with a pencil or write like make
correct so there's a couple different
things that we are looking at here
because you know what we put in our
mouth makes a world of difference of how
our cells are expressed and the science
of epigenetics actually has proven that
to be a fact now I'm so excited about
this epigenetics because for me it gave
me hope
I had been given genetic diagnoses that
I was told I would just have to live
with for the rest of my life well thanks
to the good doctor that we have on with
us today and his research and all of his
Publications and his dedication to being
on the radio for the last
I always get this wrong it's either 27
or 32 years
32.
32 years providing information
that helps us help ourselves now Dr Joel
Wallach he started out as a student in a
Pathology Lab he became a a doctor of
veterinary medicine he took his
schooling and his education and went on
some
big time
conservation type
Expeditions is what I'm going to call it
Dr Wallach because you were in South
Africa you were one of the you well you
were the lead pathologist on
the efforts to save the White Rhino
where in Africa they were with what just
a couple hundred and 350 left
350. can you imagine such a large animal
and only having 350 left
on the face of this Earth and then to be
part of a program that brought it back
and last year there were 21
000 21 000 yes in the reserves that we
built with all the Lakes We Built they
have permanent water and all that kind
of stuff all our efforts paid off 21 000
by actual account
that is fantastic Dr Wallach and I love
the fact that you are doing that for
mankind also
so folks there has been a decline in
health for so many years and different
eating Styles and recommendations and
avoid this and avoid that I mean things
that
our body needs
has just contributed to that decline in
health and the information that you're
going to be hearing here on daily with
Doc is information that is empowering to
give you the raw ingredients that are
needed to start putting those cells back
into a state of being able to
function properly because you know our
body is made up of billions of cells
and when they're sick the whole body
starts to decline well we're here to
give information that stops that Decline
and gives you that again that ability to
write your health Journey so with
further ado
everybody if you're here on live with us
raise your hand if you have a question
that you would like to ask Dr Wallach
you can go to the zoom in your find
reactions and raise hand I will be
calling on people
who have their hand raised and trying to
get them in the order that the hand was
raised and if you're on any of the
platforms rumble or YouTuber Facebook
and you have questions you can go ahead
and write those questions in the chat
too we do have Ruth Ellen who is
monitoring that check to help us get you
the information that you need as well if
you have questions and you have never
spoken to us anybody that's associated
with youngevity you do not have a health
coach or a distributor that you're
working with we do have a call team that
is standing by to help you as well that
number is
855-949-3377 again
daily with Doc call team
855-949-3377 so Dr Wallach I know you
have some information and a topic that
you would like to start us off with go
ahead please and
what would you like to talk about today
okay well just before we get to that I
do want to remind people we do have a
book called Rhino Express that actually
documents that Rhino uh saving project
Rhino Express
and if you're interested in conservation
if you're interested in a story I think
it's time to have a second edition of
that book with the story here
um
we're at now compared to where we were
back in uh
1965 when I went to South Africa for two
years
okay so it's time for the second edition
but the original book we do have some
available it's uh called Rhino express
it goes into great detail of the two
years I spent there to save the white
rhinos I'm very very proud of that
okay then um today I want to talk about
exercise exercise can be a very very
good thing healthful it can be a very
very bad thing it'll kill you okay and
when you look at what's going on
um on the news on TV on the radio online
uh wherever newspapers wherever you look
um there's every day there's young
athletes in their teens and 20s and 30s
and 40s and famous people
entertainers in their teams and 20s and
30s and 40s and 50s who are dying okay
of suddenly with no history of illness
or just dying of hypertrophy kind of
Mappy heart attacks which is a very
simple nutritional deficiencies
and of course um
and I went to China with Dr Milan we did
1 700 autopsies on kids on a major 10 in
hailing Zhong Province at tishon
University 1700
it died and what's called Keyshawn
disease there a very sudden heart death
and
um is written in three languages in
Mandarin Cantonese and English
and so that that story
um really is a what should I say a big
big story and um
is one of my biggest
projects on a single disease all right
and so
um that that I did receive the cloud
Schwartz award for that okay very proud
of that in 2011. I did get the 2015 the
Lifetime Achievement Award from the
United Nations for that so very proud of
that and uh so it just it was a great
thing to be able to save as many people
as we did and get the information out
there that will help save others also
that information with my attorney
Jonathan emord we've sued the FDA eight
times in federal court on that one
subject and we forced the manufacturers
of baby formulas Infamous Similac and
the like to put these minerals into the
baby Farmers which they weren't doing
and doctors were saying don't put any
vitamins and minerals and baby formulas
you'll kill the babies blah blah blah
will we prove to the federal judge is
that we needed to do that we did it
within 90 days we stopped new cases
of let's see here physical process which
they believe were a genetic thing was a
simple nutritional efficiencies we got
rid of physical both we got rid of
musculosphere gave the information to
Jerry Lewis
um he was so excited and he went with us
and one of our great people who we're
going to talk to tomorrow okay
got a toe in Utah we have some big
project with much history and
um
he saw that we had cured these kids and
my biopsies that they didn't have much
fishy anymore he took that information
in
um September 4th of 2011. where he was
going to put on his his Telethon okay
for the monstrously association for whom
he had raised 2.6 billion with a B 2.6
billion dollars over 46 years
and he was so excited he told them we
had found the Cure well they terminally
they summarily terminated him okay they
shut down the Telethon the next day
and then a couple years later Jerry
Lewis died but he knew I'm just so
thankful that he knew before he died
that all his efforts had contributed
to getting rid of much history and then
of course as another
um thing that we got out of that
um
information uh and putting all these
nutrients into the baby formulas we
eliminated suddenly death syndrome SIDS
which doctors said for years and years
and years and years and years and years
the doctor said
that son of a death syndrome should were
caused by the mother of sleeping on the
babies and suffocating them but once we
put the nutrition in the baby formulas
syndrome just stopped you don't hear
about silica roses anymore you don't
hear about mushrooms anymore you don't
hear about sedimentation anymore because
I'm the guy who got rid of those three
diseases now do you think there's been
one Medical School contact me
to tell the story no in the newspapers a
lot we were in magazines a lot okay
about that and so I'm very very proud of
that we do have CDs we have the books
and so forth and of course my newest
book The Wallace Revolution there you go
goes into a 75-year track okay where we
highlight
a lot of our most important findings I
mean we've have over 600 different
diseases we have programs for but we we
talk about some of the biggest ones and
some of the biggest well-known people
including Pat Boone and Danny Glover and
Andy young Theo Ratliff Evander
Holyfield and me many people like that
who we had helped them cure their
diseases with our nutritional programs
and so this book The Wallach Revolution
is now going out there and it's really
hitting the streets hard and so I want
you to take a copy of this book and some
of our CDs and epigenetics that book and
Hell's Kitchen the book and dead doctors
online take it to your local newspapers
take it to your local TV stations take
it to your local radio stations and
let's get on there and get some people
coming to you for information okay we
can save all these young athletes we can
save all these young people
um because it's just tragic for them
them in this day and age should die of a
nutritional deficiency because doctors
are saying it's caused by genetics okay
so with all that said I want to talk
about exercise today and of course
I lettered in wrestling and football in
junior high and high school and I
lettered in wrestling at the University
of Missouri I only weighed 110 pounds I
wrestled 120 pounds but they wouldn't
let me play football because you had to
be 150 pounds to play football at the
University of Missouri but I did let her
in football
in junior high in high school because
they didn't have a weight requirement
and I was tough enough and strong enough
fast enough and learned enough to be
able to successfully play football
without getting hurt myself but I did
put some lumps on a few other guys
so with all that said well today I want
to talk about exercise okay because I
have a lot of experience with that both
personally on the field
and also in the autopsy room sadly okay
and
um
we do have a three CD set that I want
everybody to get whether you personally
are exercising or not this is good for
your family good for your friends and
your church mates your neighbors okay
there's a new Bull in town There's a new
Bull in town okay there you go there's a
new bowl in town and
Red Bull has one mineral in it magnesium
and they picked that because the very
famous Bruce Lee the guy who was
considered to be the fitness Guru by
every country in the world in the 1960s
died in 1973 at age
32 of a heart attack because he was only
taking one mineral magnesium because
medical doctors convinced him if he just
ate rights he could get everything he
needed and he died 32.
I'm a heart attack in 1973 tragic tragic
tragic story
so our
let's see our sports drink rebound has
100 nutrients and at Red Bull as I said
only has one and of course CD number one
is
um CD number one is dead athletes don't
lie goes into many
20 and 30 year old professional athletes
Olympic athletes and University athletes
and why they're dying because of
nutritional deficiencies
and then
the second CD is exercise while
supplementation of suicide because when
you exercise you sweat everybody knows
them people say well yeah I exercise
twice a day and I rehydrate right away
with water I said well
how many minerals are you taking he said
what do you mean I eat well well do you
take
um our
rebound or his first drink within 75
minerals and
um no okay do you take Red Bull some say
yes some say no well Red Bull only has
one mineral we have 75 minerals okay and
the cause of death in these young
athletes is a mineral deficiency okay
and so you do have to pay attention to
these details the average life
expectancy of a professional athlete in
America
is
57.3 I believe it is okay when you look
at profession when you look at um uh
billionaires the life expected and
that's CD number three what kills
billionaires the life expectancy of
billionaires in America is 66.7
why is it so low well that's because
they exercise they exercise they
exercise they rehydrate afterwards but
nobody tells them that sweat is a soup
with the minerals in your body when
you're sweating you're sweating out not
only water and you're also sweating out
the minerals if you're just drinking
water rehydrate you're slowly
killing yourself exercise without
supplementation is suicide so get that
three CD set add 25 to 50 Health years
your life use our rebound has 75
minerals in it and 25 vitamins amino
acids uh the the energy drinks of course
came out 1985 Coca-Cola came out with
one called Monster okay and
um let's see here
in 1987 an Austrian and I I'm going to
get his name wrong I know uh dietrichs
dietrichs
Matrix Matrix okay uh he was one okay
from Austrian and Austria not Australian
and Austrian came up with Red Bull
and put the one mineral in their
magnesium so it'd be like um the thing
that uh
um and everybody thinks that everybody
thinks that
um Bruce Lee was killed was shot okay no
no he died of a heart attack he wasn't
shot okay and then of course Monster
again is a Coca-Cola product 1985. Pepsi
Cola came out with Rockstar in 2001 and
we came out in youngevity with our
Rebound in 2011.
okay well rebound
has a 75 minerals in it and 25 volumes
amino acids Red Bull
has
um
let's see here
four vitamins
and one mineral
no oh yeah one middle magnesium and then
Rockstar has one mineral in five
vitamins
and so you know use your brains get our
rebound and get 75 minerals and 25
bottoms amino acids and get this CD set
for you and all the people in your
family who exercise because exercise
without supplementation is suicide you
will kill yourself early
okay don't do that well why did why did
she die why did he die they were
exercising twice a day three times a day
on Saturday and Sunday and they were
really really working hard and they they
bought expensive water and rehydrated
Rapture their exercise well sweat is not
just water sweat is a soup of all your
minerals and you're sweating them out
you should be replacing what you're
sweating out but you also have to re not
only replace what you're sweating out
but you also have to take extra
to keep adding to the store of these
nutrients in your body and again the
wallet Revolution goes into this in
great detail okay I I urge you to
um if you get 10 of these you get 10 of
any of our titles you get a nice
discount
um the book epidex is a summary of my
thesis which is in the Smithsonian
Institute as a National Treasure okay
exercise all right
epigenetics and then Hell's Kitchen
tells you the transition from wood and
coal to fuel for thousands and thousands
and thousands of years
and we use the wood ashes and coal ashes
as a fertilizer because they're like 95
98 minerals and two or three percent
carbon
and so the vegetables in our Gardens
would suck up all these meals we ate the
vegetables we got our minerals that way
we went to electricity at three o'clock
in the afternoon Monday September 4th
1882 when Thomas citizen pulled that
switch in New York City guess what
suddenly now we no longer had the
mineral sources that we had for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years and doctor said oh just eat well
you get everything you need
well that may have been happening
thousands of years ago but not now and
then of course we have my favorite story
is the bottomland where we have the
um hydroelectric plants and of course
they stopped all the flooding all the
spring flooding which renewed the soil
with the silt from the mountains when
the flood waters when the flood water we
see the farmers would go and plow that
silt back into soil renew the salt from
uh to previous year all the crops were
sucking the minerals out they would put
the saw back in and bottom line was the
most valuable Farmland anywhere in the
world
okay every country had bottomlands and
it's always the most expensive because
it was naturally renewing with all the
minerals because of the floods and the
silt well 1936
1936 the US had the United States Senate
came out with us in a document 264 and
said there's no longer sufficient
minerals in our soils to support healthy
longevity and human life anymore
U.S Senate said that in 1936 and u.sn
document 264. don't take my word for it
okay this is very well documented is
really a tragedy but we can make up the
difference you take your rebound you
take your 90th essential nutrients and
just remember
we need these things okay and we have
diabetes diabetes has made genetic
disease diabetes very simple nutritional
deficiency if if you're taking
um diabetic medication either oral or
injectable get our healthy blood sugar
pack if you're not taking any one of our
products yet take our healthy blood
sugar pack which is our Healthy Start
pack has the 90 essential nutrients 60
minerals 16 vitamins 12 medicines Three
fatty acids plus it has the
um the sweeties added to it okay it
becomes a healthy blood sugar pack
and the type 2 diabetes will go away
okay don't call turkey off your
medication but as your blood sugar drops
you can still reduce medication okay
right now
we're spending 342 billion dollars a
year in the United States alone just to
treat the symptoms of type 2 diabetes
every year in America not to
preventative we can prevent it we can
cure it
okay come to us if your doctor is just
giving you injections or pills to lower
your blood sugar
um the doctor is not giving you the
benefit of all the knowledge that's
known okay
um so try us
because 90 days it'll blow your mind
okay
um
there's 96 million pre-diabetics in
America
96 million pre-diabetics in America
that's because they're deficient in
these nutrients okay
and then arthritis arthritis is one of
the medical system's most favorite
diseases why
because we spend each year in America
just to treat the symptoms of arthritis
626.8 billion 626.8 billion
and then 2.3 trillion to treat
osteoporosis together is over three
trillion dollars each year just to treat
the symptoms of osteoporosis and
arthritis which is osteoporosis of your
joints okay
give us a try Okay healthy brand heart
pack MSM collagen peptides
let's see here
don't forget vitamin D3 okay and
uh don't forget our Rebound Sports drink
even if you're not exercising take her
as four strength is another way to get
more nutrients into your bones your
joints and so forth give us 90 days and
see what you say about your arthritis
and of course there are 37 different
diseases you get from osteoporosis of
the skull
and that book goes along really well
um it's all in your head there's a CD
that goes along with it it's a book and
CD set
um this is something that um Dr Milan
and Rebecca and myself did okay and my
favorite picture of course is a set of
pictures
in the front is a Roman numeral number
six page number six Roman numeral number
six in the book it's on your head
37 different diseases
the skull cap is removed okay on the top
one but look at the thickness of the
skull it's only a quarter of an inch
thick as normal
the bottom one
okay here's the top of the skull is cut
off you're looking down on the brain but
look at how thick it is it's an inch and
a half to two inches thick you can see
we'd be squeezing those 12 pairs of
cranial nerves coming out right and left
side of your head and of course the
spinal cord coming out of the back
creating 37 different diseases which
your doctors refer their classmates to
who become Specialists as dentists ear
nose and throat doctors okay
doctors who deal
with back problems and so forth like
including chiropractors and dos and that
kind of stuff
uh these are all totally 100 reversible
these are all 100 totally 100
preventable
okay get a hold of these books and CDs
get the nutrients the healthy remain in
heart pack MSM
um our collagen peptides and then we
have secret sauces for over 600
different diseases oh my gosh and this
is where the books and the CDs and DVDs
come in they can add 25 to 50 health
careers to your life with all that said
um I'm going to turn it over to Rebecca
oh doctor well like there's a lot of
people that don't realize
that the reason why
you well actually he mentioned a lot of
different products just now folks you
can't get these at your corner store Dr
Wallach couldn't find them at the corner
store so he developed teams of people
that have put these nutrients into
formulas that then can be
purchased and acquired but he he
couldn't find them anywhere so he took
his research and put them together
and with that he became the founder of a
company called youngevity
so youngevity it's it was American
Longevity but
then we couldn't you know expand beyond
the American borders we had North
America South America and that's it well
folks we took that or they took that and
made it just youngevity
and we are now around the world and I
love that
I love being able to use zoom like we're
doing today to broadcast this message
there's different phone apps that we can
use where we can communicate there are
no boundaries
when it comes to communication and
reaching out and touching people there
should be no boundaries in being able to
provide not only the information but the
actual products and raw ingredients
needed for people to not just survive
but thrive
so Dr Wallach you have done so much in
your short Lifetime and I think you have
made a bigger impact than any doctor I
have ever met
and because of the impact that you've
made in my life
I am very proud to be here as the
hostess of daily with Doc with you we
thank you for all your contributions and
all your your ability to help so many
people and get that message out there
and so
um you're a five-star general in the
team and we appreciate you for it
well thank you so much Dr Wallach I I
appreciate you saying that for sure
well if you were invited by anybody to
watch this program to watch the replay
or the live broadcast make sure that you
get back with them and say hey what do
you know about this company youngevity
do you have a special place that I can
get the products that I need because
folks you can find products on some of
these big retail online stores but what
you're not going to find you are not
going to find the Personal Touch of a
health coach somebody that you can ask
questions from and get answers that are
based on Dr wallach's research so we
want to make sure that you're getting
correct information and that you're
getting the support that you deserve so
make sure that you get a hold of your
youngevity associate and if you don't
have one and you have never spoken to
anybody about youngevity or the products
make sure or Dr Wallach okay make sure
that you get get in touch with us again
go to daily withdoc.com there you will
find a contact us you can also reach out
to us that way if you yourself are
interested in helping us in this mission
to get products and information to
people that will help them restore their
lives as well so use that contact us
send us an email let us know what you're
interested in if you are part of our
newsletter team and your res you're here
because you received the newsletter
invitation you can do a reply back to
that newsletter and Dr Wallach we have
lots of hands up I don't think we're
going to get to questions that were
emailed in because I have hundreds of
those so let's go ahead and get started
go to Ms Lewis hello and welcome
hold on hold on
there
try to unmute now
how about in the middle of your screen
do you see a request to unmute
yeah oh that works there you go we hear
you loud and clear now
okay uh my grandson has fabry disease
apparently a lacks an enzyme and they
have a shunt in his
shoulder
okay
what symptoms does he have
uh he just doesn't digest his food
apparently
okay so digestion absorption oh do you
know what he eats for breakfast uh yeah
probably
probably junk food
okay well I need more information
there is an ordinary diet I imagine he's
cereal and probably eggs and
oatmeal does he eat oatmeal does he eat
Wheaties does he Cheerios does he eat
pancakes does he eat waffles what does
he eat
All the Above
yeah yeah the classical American diet
you have we have digestion problems the
odds are
you're eating glutinous foods and the
first thing we need to get for him is
the book 300 Page book it's called Dr
Wallace cooking without the bad foods it
has 300 pages of safe recipes and safe
cooking methods okay can you jump on
that right away
then everybody in the household has got
to jump on that so there's no
cross-contamination the laundry and the
couches and the beds and the rugs and
all that kind of stuff then
um he needs to do you have any idea how
much he weighs
uh he's about 11 and he's fairly small
so I don't know but
11 maybe 65 70 pounds Maybe
like that probably okay all right so
let's have him take one
well first of all he's got to get rid of
all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed Meats okay we're talking about
ham and bacon and bologna and salami and
hot dogs and all that kind of stuff
because they have nitrates in there
which are bad for the thyroid and all
the other tissues and including the
brain and so forth
then he needs to uh again no fried food
no processed Meats no oils no glutens
when I say no oils I mean no cooking
oils no salad dressings I like to use
um dairy cream and also yogurt for my
salad dressings if I'm going to use
salad dressing
and then
I want him to also to avoid gluten wheat
bread around oats includes cereals and
pancakes and waffles and all that kind
of stuff
um breads spaghetti all that stuff's got
to go if he has spaghetti it's got to be
rice spaghetti rice noodles you've got
to eat like an Asian if you've got to
eat like an Asian in southern China and
in Japan and so forth okay
um because they they use rice and sweet
potatoes and beans and vegetables that
kind of stuff
um northern China they eat wheat okay in
northern China they live five years less
they die five years earlier than the
people in the South because of South
China they live on Rice they're not
getting the gluten okay and then
absolutely no sugar no sugar of any kind
and then absolutely no
um carbon or drinks
okay that includes everything no carbon
or drinks including water because
carbonation neutralizes stomach acid so
you cannot absorb minerals or digest
food and then I want him to use we have
two Salt types of salt we sell one of
seasoned salt from Australia and also we
have one called the Himalayan salt which
is from the Himalayan Mountains and
they're both salt from
volcanic eruptions and they have 28 to
30 different minerals in there as well
as the sodium chloride if you have a
doctor who says don't use salts because
you could have a pressure find a
different doctor
salt is required by every cell in your
body the sodium is required for
functions
um metabolic functions inside the cell
and the chlorine what do you think the
shunt is doing to them they they he has
a shunt in his Soldier shoulder and they
put that enzyme that he lacks in that
shunt every month without doing to him
we're just doing it once a month I think
it's what once a month okay well we have
okay well we have an enzyme he could
take we call it the gallbladder in a
model it's called ultimate enzymes it
does have bile in it so it's like the
gallbladder as well as the stomach doing
the enzymes but he does need the salt
and so he can use our seasoned salt from
Australia or he can use our Himalayan
salt from the Himalayan Mountains okay
and we also have the enzyme called
please
what is the enzyme called ultimate
enzymes
ultimate yeah like the best of the best
the top of the top ultimate enzymes
yeah the nickname is uh gallbladder in a
bottle because it does have bile in it
to help you absorb fat soluble vitamins
and
um essential fatty acids and that kind
of stuff okay I take three of those
twice a day I weigh 142.
okay so give us a call every week or so
um let us know how uh and this is your
grandson yeah I don't know if his
parents will follow this but I just
wondered what you thought about it well
you need to he's going to be in big
trouble
terribly along with that disease well
well he better start our program and
then he can he can live 50 years longer
than they predict
that's good
okay yeah a parent should say okay if
it's not going to kill him I want to try
anything I can to help him and so
um we can guarantee we're going to help
him but he's got to cooperate he can't
be sneak eating
Wheaties he can't be sneak eating
spaghetti you know after school
someplace
he cannot be eating waffles from Waffle
House and all that kind of stuff he's
got to stay on the diet he has a brother
who is supposed to be gluten free but
his brother has to live in a house full
of gluten anyway yeah so they're getting
cross-contaminated in the laundry and
the couches and all that kind of stuff
yeah okay well this is not a small thing
I know he will kill him 25 years early
yeah
and so he needs to be spoken to and he
can get on and get on you know with us
uh Monday through Friday uh noon to one
Pacific time and he can get on here and
talk to us his parents can get on here
and talk with us this is not a small
thing you can you can add 25 to 50
healthful years of his life but if he
can he's going down that track uh this
is going to be a very very bad outcome
for him
yeah that's what I figure uh how about
the does he you want him to take like a
healthy
um I I said all that you know they held
the Brandon hard pack for 100 pounds of
body weight he needs the MSM
running hard pack yeah okay that's our
big hammered has 215 nutrients including
the 90. he also needs our rebound or a
sports drink not Red Bull
his arm Red Bull only has one mineral we
have 75 minerals anymore
getting our rebound and if he wants to
cans he's got to pop the tops on him at
night before he goes to bed put in the
refrigerator so be all the bubbly's gone
in the morning
we do have the sticks which he could
take to school during the day there's
100 nutrients in here we do have the
canisters which is a powder there's 30
sticks in a box and there's 36 servings
in the canister there's 12 cams and a
case of the cans but you do have to pop
the tops on because they do have
carbonation in them okay
yeah thank you okay let's hear from you
because we want to save this kid okay
yeah I wish we could well we can
well his parents have to agree to it of
course that's correct
oh Ms Lewis we have a program that was
recorded and you can find it on daily
with doc.com that goes through uh serial
killers and that what gluten actually
does within the body I highly recommend
finding that on our website
dailywithdoc.com and as a parent
especially if I have two kiddos with
digestive issues and one of them is
supposed to be gluten free
we need to take this serious as parents
if we have our children's best interest
in mind
because it is a serious condition very
serious and but it's a simple solution
and that's where the medical
Society just makes it more and more
difficult it's a simple solution to a
very serious issue yeah so we're going
to keep you in our thoughts and prayers
as you're sharing information with them
to help Empower them to make the best
choices for their for their sons
they have a son that has to be
gluten-free but he lives in the
environment full of gluten of course
well if I had a son that had to be
gluten-free I would be gluten-free
myself just to set an example and make
it easier for the whole household
that's that's me personally but you know
we all have our own thing and what is
the uh what is the uh thing you just
gave me
um
it's a website daily with
doc.com and if you turn the chat on we
will have one of the hostesses or one of
the co-host this is put that link in the
chat so that you can go ahead and and
grab it there too and know exactly what
to do we also have the Good Foods bad
foods list that is on the website that
you will be able to grab and share with
them that goes through what Dr Wallach
has found to be yeah
bad health so make sure you share that
with them as well
thank you so much
let's go ahead and go to the next hand
that is up Dr Wallach in our next 10
minutes here and Rob go ahead you are on
live with Dr Wallach hi Becca did you
say it did I raise my hand very funny
you know I can't raise my hand yet
I'm getting there I'm getting there hi
doc
um yes sir doc first of all you
mentioned uh of course we know you've
helped out a lot of celebrities in
public figures uh we have a big one
coming up sir we have a very well-known
uh celebrity with Parkinson's we're
gonna help her out
um and I'm gonna try and get you on into
a documentary as well too so uh we're
going to discuss that very soon uh
that's going to be very fantastic for us
um so anyways I'll discuss that with you
later okay meanwhile
um my owner nerve injury is healing I'm
getting
um movement back into my fingers I'm
still having a whole arm ache
um but I'm still dealing with my hyper
retention as well too I'm using I'm
taking
um four ultimate daily Classics two
times a day and it's helped out a lot uh
but I need your guidance for a little
bit more okay well when you have high
blood pressure there's several things
you have to do number one you have to
stay away from the bad stuff equally as
well as taking the good stuff
and the bad stuff of course includes the
bad foods the gluten wheat bun around
oats uh we're talking about
um buckwheat
and because they destroy the lining the
small intestines so instead of looking
like a shag rug it looks like a plastic
tube you lose 95 of your absorptive
surface and no matter how many
supplements you take if you're eating
something bad and killing your villi
it's all coming out the other end into
the septic tank and the bugs in the
septic tank are getting the benefit of
all those vitamins and minerals instead
of you okay this is not difficult
concept
but the Habit pressure requires two
things stay away from the bad stuff so
you can absorb and number two you take
all the good stuff and how much do you
weigh now Rob I'm still in the 200 pound
range I'm six foot one okay well again
um get rid of all the bad foods no fried
foods no processed Meats no oils no
glutens no wheat nobody around those so
sugar no carbonated drinks you know the
carbonated water needs to go and then
once you take a two healthy brand hard
Pass a month a photo of everything twice
a day there's 215 nutrients take a photo
of everything twice a day I want you to
take two valves a month of our MSM so
you can take three of breakfast sweet
lunch at dinner time that's going to
help rebuild your bones and cartilage
and ligaments and tendons and connective
tissue including the bone marrow
um also I want you to take our let's see
here the collagen peptides and the
collagen peptides I want you to take a
scoop of that with your morning drinks
with your evening drink and you're
taking those ultimate daily classic cows
that's good they will help support and
promote the
um rebuilding of the walls of your
arteries and your veins including in
your skull and your heart and your
kidneys which
produce blood pressure issues if you
have problems going on in your kidneys
or in kidney arteries
um
but the fact that you're making progress
is a good sign but just really crank
down and make sure that you're doing all
the good stuff and then you know we look
forward to hearing about all this good
news you have coming up and so stay in
touch okay but thanks for the progress
report and keep obviously you're doing a
lot of good things correctly so keep
doing it
and thank you very much doc I couldn't
do it without you either
um God bless you and of course we have
the whole young Jody team including
um uh our our telephone team here
including the chief uh Rebecca here I'm
making sure that you're going the right
direction Becca you're doing an
absolutely fantastic job uh with daily
with Doc I have never seen a better zoom
in my life congrats everybody needs to
apply to Rebecca and her team what a
fantastic job thank you very much
thank you Rob and you actually have the
the general of generals right under Dr
well like with Char uh one of our good
friends who was on with Dr Wallach on
The Daily or Dead Doctors Don't Lie show
for many years so yeah
once in a while yeah
it was on the dead doctor's not live for
32 years
yeah I missed the shark are you there
you know so we always everyone she does
a zoom on Wednesday afternoons yes I
know I'm not on that no more bro that's
been hijacked uh I prefer all right
thank you rob thank you Becca okay
so let's go ahead and move right over
now Bobby go ahead unmute yourself
hello Dr walek and thank you again uh
Rebecca dukes and uh
holistic coaches we have a female doctor
wallet she's 46 years old
130 pounds
five four
and she has
fibroids
and she drinks alcohol and then smokes a
lot
okay well he's getting rid of all the
bad stuff give her all that inflammation
okay fibroids are actually fibrous
connective tissue in the genital tract
okay from the uterus all the way down to
the outside okay and then the connective
tissue so she needs to get rid of all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils no glutens no
wheat and round notes no sugar no carbon
or drinks
including carbonated water
I do want her to have at 136 pounds or
130 pounds she's right at that cusp I
started her out with two healthy branded
hard packs a month a full dose of
everything twice a day uh that's 215
nutrients okay to have the brain hard
pressure multiple photos filling twice a
day then I wanted to have the MSM two
bottles of our MSM so you could take
three at breakfast sweet lunch for
dinner time they're going to support and
promote men's repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
including in the uterus in the vagina
and all the tubes and everything okay
and then she also needs two bottles a
month of our xerofem x e r a dash fem
zerofem take three of those twice a day
that's two bottles a month
and they provide the cells of the
ovaries and the tubes in the uterus with
what they need to make all the hormones
which make things work properly and and
be of the proper structure and so forth
and then
um again uh she needs to uh wouldn't
hurt to
um to take some of the digestive enzymes
or ultimate enzymes you could take two
or three of those say five or ten
minutes for each meal so she can absorb
all this good stuff
and then contact us every couple of
weeks because the
um
female sexual system recovers very
quickly think about it you know it
builds a baby in nine months it goes
back down to normal in a couple of weeks
and so it has an enormous capacity to to
repair itself given all the raw
materials and stand away from the bad
stuff okay
all right all right thank you so much
Bobby let's go ahead at Stephanie go
ahead and unmute yourself
thank you Rebecca
um my questions are very unusual
compared to what a lot of people put in
here mine is a question about goats
um I have
two things that I'm very interested
um there's a a disease that they get is
called CL and
um
I and and and the other the other thing
that's uh an issue is bullying and I'm
I've noticed even though we have the the
mineral blocks in there specifically to
make sure they have the stuff for having
good babies and stuff the younger ones
um 100 or less
um they they don't seem to be able to
get in it because
um one dropped very early yesterday and
I was very perplexed and I thought oh my
goodness she's not getting enough
nutrition I thought ah bullying the
bully they're keeping them away from
the the nutrient stain and so um so what
would I do okay well what is the I don't
know what CL means oh it it's some kind
of a
some kind of a um
they get lumps in their body
um that uh if it's broken it can spread
throughout the herd really quick
according to what they say and then um
and they recommend you getting rid of
them because it can spread through the
whole group and then and then and then
okay stop are you saying this is
infectious is this a bug yes
okay so
um yeah if this is if this is a bug
um you need to make sure they're getting
a big Trace mineral salt block okay and
of course we have our uh plant derived
minerals and so forth that they should
have access to and of course uh also
um
in their feed uh you want to make sure
that they're getting our
um
minerals in our feet in their feed to
get our minerals and they can if they
have
half Drums of water instead of running
water if they have running water in a
creek you can't add it there because
it'll be gone in a few minutes but if
they're if they're getting their water
from a drum okay or a bucket then you
can put the plant minerals there okay
and they do need to have the
um
uh what should I say
we do have the
salt
if I may insert it's coming up as
costius lymphedentitis a bacterial
infection of the lymph nodes
okay well they have a bacterial
infection in lymph nodes they need to
get some antibiotics but also I wanted
to have to support their immune system
or arthrodex and
um it's like
um for small animals it's like one scoop
for 20 pounds of body weight but for a
goat okay for a goat
um you might wonder young and they
weighs 25 30 40 50 pounds they could
have
Two Scoops it's one scoop for 20 pounds
of body weight of the Archer decks and
it'll support the immune system but they
if they have an infection they need to
be getting some you know the farmer
needs to go through there and give them
all injections of the right antibiotic
and ask the veterinarian what antibiotic
they need to be giving them and so forth
and so do that but also to support the
immune system they need the arthradex
one scoop for 20 pounds of body weight
we sell a lot of that for for goats and
llamas and horses and calves and pigs
and chickens and all kinds of stuff
um dogs and cats so it's used by all
Critters okay arthrodex
so let us know how it works for you okay
all right thank you sir
all right thank you so much Stephanie
now Dr willick we're at the end of our
show we just want to thank you so much
again for coming on and sharing with us
your knowledge in regards to animal and
human health folks
where where mammals
we incr we need the 90 essential
nutrients the same foods are destroying
our bodies and the cells so why not make
decisions that help us out for a longer
enjoyable life
I know there's a lot of people well I
enjoy this I enjoy this I enjoy this yes
but if this it's something that you
enjoy is causing this damage within the
body and you're looking at the
increasing the possibilities of having
this this this and this which is very
painful
why would you continue it yeah why would
you give up 25 years of your life for
the people you love because you like the
taste of something
yeah is it is it really worth it
that's my question well Dr Wallach
value your
so much worth my time to spend this time
with you and just help bring your
message to the world so thank you so
much for all that you do thank you thank
you for you and your team and all the
good job that you all do together to
support our program here uh daily with
Doc I can't thank you enough and uh and
step right up to the plate because we
have been doing for two years uh asdoc
live right
um on Fridays and so it's not like we're
strangers and then suddenly now we have
the opportunity to go from
Monday a week to five days a week so we
were prepared we were practiced we can't
thank you enough for bringing your team
along and we'll do this for another 50
to 100 years that's our goal that's our
goal thank you so much Dr Wallach you
have a fabulous fabulous day thank you
all right and thank you everybody for
being here with us and if I could get my
co-hosts on with me that would
absolutely be fantastic because I
couldn't do this without them
we have so many things that are going on
in the background with collecting
information providing information in the
chat making sure that people get into
the zoom room with us and making sure
that they are behaving so and then of
course the broadcast
all of these different components where
we are looking for people who have
skills that they would like to bring to
the table and help us with this Mission
and crusade to get Dr Wallace
message out there and you know
if you have those skills and you would
like to share those skills get with the
person who invited you to this program
if you were not invited by anybody's
specifically you found us on one of our
live streams make sure that you get back
with us here at Daily with Doc and use
that contact us I will make sure that
you get in contact with one of our
certified holistic health coaches to
help you in achieving what your desires
are if it comes to health if it comes to
creating an additional end screen
additional stream of income yes I can
speak
um we are here to help and we're looking
forward to helping you reach your goals
so on behalf of myself Becca dukes and
our co-hosts Phyllis Anderson Sherry
Browning Marilyn pazera and Roselyn
Sanchez thank you for joining us here on
daily with Doc we'll talk to you later
bye for now
three
[Music]
two
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign